yes so okay uh last but not least uh
stefan wojtovich uh
who is uh currently at texas a m
university and i think
permanently he's gonna talk about
continuous time to get the gradient
descent and flat minimum selection
thank you so much and thank you
so much for uh to katie and simone for
inviting me to this wonderful workshop
and everybody who has already given us
such wonderful presentations
so yes i'm going to continue a little
bit in the vein of the previous talk and
talk about the training of neural
networks
um and stochastic gradient descent so uh
the outline of my talk is to talk a
little bit about the
lost landscape and the
specifics of optimization problems in
deep learning
and then to talk a little bit about the
continuous time
analysis and what
what kind of minima we see
so
in class uh the tasks in machine
learning and classical numerical
analysis are not that different in the
sense that we've got a data set
and we're trying to fit
values y i at points x i
or at least that is the loss function
that we minimize
and in the classical theory we've got uh
techniques and we know the bounds for
that we've got polynomial interpolation
or spline interpolation
and we know that sometimes these methods
work very well and sometimes these
methods totally fail so we've got the
round phenomenon
as one example of that and in modern
tech uh modern interpolation we've got a
data set which is in a very high
dimensional space so we need new tools
for that we use neural networks uh
if we
if we want to
and we
the one of the
key features of neural networks is that
they are over parametrized so in
classical interpolation we've got as
many parameters as we've got data points
or if we don't trust our data points
that much and assume that there is noise
we've got actually fewer parameters and
we've got under parameterized learning
and neural networks have challenged this
classical paradigm of using
underparameterized function classes
and yet they seem to work very well and
it's still not entirely clear to us what
the reasons for that are
so because
the functions
depend non-linearly on both the
parameters and the data
it is
not that easy to find optimal parameters
and what we do is to
penalize a loss function that in the
simplest case just takes the difference
of the output that we would like to see
and the difference of the output that we
have
and then squares it sums it up takes the
average
so
we've got an optimization problem and
that is the problem that i'll focus on
today and that is unlike the previous
talk for
empirical risk for empirical loss with
finite amounts of data
and not for infinite data
so
one thing to note is that if we've got a
data set with n points
and we've got a parametrized function
model so we've got m parameters
n data points in our d
and the function is reasonably smooth in
the parameters
and we assume that for any y1
through yn there exists some parameter
such that our function
fits the data
fits the values that we'd like to see
exactly
then the set of minimizers of our loss
functional
is the set of parameters where our
function fits
the data exactly
and that is an m minus n-dimensional
sub-manifold of the parameter space
and if our function model is lipschitz
continuous in theta
then
we
and we can fit
and it's expressive enough to fit data
around arbitrary outputs at an
additional point then this manifold is
non-compact
so the proof is very simple it's
basically
we've got m parameters n constraints
and formally we apply the regular value
theorem and sarri's theorem and that
tells us that almost every
pre-image
of
y
um i
here under the function where we just
look at the outputs of the model and all
the data points
is a
regular enough manifold
and for compactness we just see that if
we can fit arbitrary our labels at one
additional point then we can take two
points in our manifold that must be far
apart because the output at the last
point is
can be chosen arbitrarily far apart
so
we've got a very high dimensional set of
minimizers which is generally a manifold
and usually a curved manifold
so
the big question that i was getting
curious about is
that there are many many minimizers
there's a continuum of minimizers of
this loss function
and some of them memorize the data set
so if you give your students a finite
number of examples
and tell them those are going to be on
the exam then some will understand the
pattern underneath the examples and some
will memorize the data set
and neural networks can basically do
either and the question is
what do we see or why do we often seem
to see
the case that we actually understand
some meaningful structure in the set
and so which minimizers do we find when
we train our neural networks and
training to me will be following the
stochastic gradient descent of the loss
function
and the conjecture is that we find
minimizers where the energy landscape is
flat in some sense
because if
if it's not flat then you've got small
scale oscillations
or
instabilities were moving slightly could
throw off something
but that's that's going to become more
precise in a little bit and something
that i'm not going to talk about at all
today is the conjecture that flat
minimizers generalize better and i think
this is the first occurrence of that
flat minimum selection conductor
and it's been studied since
and so
let's talk a bit more about the lost
landscape of neural networks so
as in the previous talk a neural network
let's say a shallow neural network
is a function that is just a sum a i
sigma of some linear function of x
and um if
the statement is if we've got more
neurons than data points then we can fit
any values at a given set of data points
so and if we are in one dimension then
that is pretty trivial because if
m is greater or equal to n
and say we use relu activation
then
what we've got
are a bunch of points here
and our relu is expressive enough to
allow us to do something piecewise
linear and so we can just interpolate
that with a piecewise linear function
with n plus one segments or something
so
we
so we can see
that in one dimension this is trivial
and in the multi-dimensional case
we uh just project this into some
direction such that the one-dimensional
projection of all the data points is
different and then we're back back in
the one-dimensional case so neural
networks are one of those function
classes that can fit random
labels and any two-layer neural network
if you just re-parameterize it can be
either expressed exactly or approximated
by a deeper neural networks
that have at most like four times as
many parameters so you still get the
ability to fit random data of course
this is very heavily over parameterized
since you've got n data points and n
times dimension parameters
but uh that is not actually crazy bound
for realistic cases where we've got
thousands tens of thousands of data
points and possibly millions of
parameters
so
any two-lane neural network uh what a
two-layer neural network can do also
certain deep neur networks can do yes
yeah
yes uh you can you can definitely reduce
this uh but this is the easiest proof
that i was aware of
because it's just a sketch on the board
um and so
under the same assumptions that we made
above
l is convex if and only if
uh the
function is linear
in the parameters not necessarily the
data points but the parameters
and the sketch that i would give you
is that if we've got a manifold of
minimizers
and the function model is non-linear
then the set where it fits the labels
exactly will generally not be exactly
linear so this is the set of minimizers
and then if i connect
two points in the set of minimizers uh
some point on this
line connecting two minimizers has to
have a negative hash
so we've got a
and we can push this a little bit
further under a bit stronger assumptions
so
if we
are
if we are
minimizing uh the loss
and the function class is non-linear
enough in the parameters
then the loss function will not be
convex in the neighborhood of any
minimizer
which means that typical
learning guarantees from stochastic
optimization
may not capture exactly what's going on
in deep learning
so that is a little bit on the
lost landscape
um
and the
the question is does this come from the
fact that we have over parameterized our
model and we only use finite amounts of
data i'm going to argue that that is not
the case
because let's just look at
the relu activation function
then we've got again these two-layer
neural networks
obviously okay we can reparameterize the
neural network by just changing the
labels on the neurons that's boring that
disappears for example
if we
pass to the empirical distribution of
the parameters
we've got another possibility that in
the outer layer we just true we just
choose the same parameters for w1 and b1
and w2 and b2
and we choose the opposite sign for a1
and a2
that also gives us a degeneracy in the
parametrization
we've got a scaling that is fairly
specific to relu
we've got an identity and this is i
think where things get a bit more
interesting so we can
express z
as relu of z minus relu of minus z
so z plus one for example can be
expressed as radius of z minus ratio of
minus z which gives us the z
plus rayleigh of one
or
we can have the we can just express the
linear function inside and then
have it outside
and so we've got many different ways of
representing the same function
and the possibly most interesting
example is so if we've got a function
just on the real line which says say has
the first derivative in bv
so a little bit less than w21
and then we can recover f of x
as a certain integral of the radial
function this is because relu basically
like the absolute value function is a
green's function for the laplacian in
one dimension because
take two derivatives and you get
a dirac delta
this also characterizes these functions
in higher dimension where rob novak
just applied a radon transform and then
you get
very similar results here
but
for example this means that if we can
represent the euclidean norm squared
along the as a function which takes the
x of x1 squared plus x2 squared that's
x3 squared so which has neurons that are
all along the coordinate axes but we can
also rotate our coordinate system and so
we can have neurons pointing in very
different directions and represent the
same function so there's a lot of
degeneracy even in the infinite data and
infinite parameter case
so
the representation of a certain function
is generally very non-unique and so
you would not get rid of this
set of this complicated set of
minimizers
all right um so
training i said is for me stochastic
gradient descent
so um that is well gradient descent is
just
i take a little time step in the
direction of the negative gradient of
the loss
which in this case is
has this specific form which is just how
well i uh
i fit my data
averaged over the data set
um stochastic gradient descent i
replaced that with a small subsample of
my uh
large data set
um i'm generally going to picture also
batch size one but um that is not a key
feature here
um and uh in general stochastic gradient
descent can be thought of as a law where
theta e plus 1 is given as theta t minus
some
step size eta times an estimator of the
gradient which gives me an unbiased
estimate of the gradient
and for the analysis i usually require
some moment bounce
so there is a long classical theory
going back to the 50s if i've got
certain moment bounds what uh what
convergence can i get
and
that does not necessarily capture what's
going on in deep learning
because so if i look at this
loss function
i can calculate the gradient i've given
that to you in the last slide i can
calculate the hessian and i can
calculate the
covariance matrix of the gradient
estimators
so um that is
the difference between the average
misfit on the data set and the true
misfit
and um
the gradient estimator
uh noise intake the noise intensity in
the gradient estimator
scales with the value of the loss
function here the way to think about
this is i am at a global minimum if and
only if i fit all my data point the
right labels and my data points exactly
so
if i fit all the data points exactly
then
none of my gradient estimators will give
me anything else than 0 because that
point is happy
so that is i think a bit like the
observation that a function is zero in
l2 if and only if it is zero in l
infinity
and so i i do fit all my data points
exactly
so i
i'm not i don't experience stochastic
noise when i'm at the global minimum
whereas if i'm far away from the global
minimum then the
then trying to
fit the constraints on different data
points may pull me in very different
directions
per data point
than the global average so i experience
a lot more noise in high noise regions
and because i have
much fewer data points than i've got
parameters
the gradient the noise in the gradient
estimator has a very low rank
and so here you see these if i'm at the
global minimum these terms are all zero
so that guy disappears
what i've got is this
product of the gradients which is
roughly the same thing that appears
in the covariance matrix of the noise
so
as an approximation something like loss
times hessian of the loss
has been
proposed but not very well studied
and there are a few studies that concern
the
low rank of the noise uh i'm going to
focus on the other part i'm going to
focus on the fact that the noise
intensity scales
with the intensity of the loss
so
this is just another way of stating this
bound so the the expected value between
the
true gradient and the gradient estimator
is bounded by some constant times the
value of the loss function
and you can exploit that
so
i'm going to gloss over this a little
bit but if i've got an objective
function where the gradient is lipschitz
that is the standard assumption for
simple analysis of gradient descent
and we've got an energy energy
dissipation inequality so basically
globally our lost landscape looks like a
valley not a convex valley but
a valley nonetheless where the set of
minimizers may be a little bit curved so
this is a
probably better assumption near the
minimum of uh
of the loss surface in
a deep learning
and
then i've got a family of gradient
estimators that have the right noise
intensity scaling
if my
step size is small enough in terms of
the problem givens
that is
then
i can prove that the expected value of
my
objective function decays exponentially
fast
along the stochastic gradient descent
and because the objective value decays
exponentially fast that actually implies
that i convert to a global minimum
and the only thing that i want to really
point out about this result is that we
can keep the step size positive
that is a massive difference to the case
of classical stochastic noise where the
noise intense where the noise intensity
does not diminish at the minimum
and so that would give you an invariant
distribution that
is concentrated around the minimum but
not actually convergence to a minimizer
whereas in deep learning we usually keep
our positive step size fixed and we
pretend that
it's small enough and that we would let
it go to zero but that's not what we do
and to an extent i would claim we don't
have to because our noise has a better
structure than say in classical
mechanics
and we can
also push this further so if our
landscape doesn't look like a valley
globally but only
on the set where the loss is high and
the la the center where the loss is
small and the noise has some nice
structure
then we can also prove
exponentially fast convergence almost
surely
but with possibly prohibitively large
constants
so the idea here is that where the loss
is high the either the gradient or the
noise helps you and where the loss is
already low the noise is not strong
enough to
mess things up for you
um but uh yeah here you see a little bit
the uh the setting that i was describing
originally if you've got noise that
doesn't vanish at the minimum you get
this kind of invariant distributions for
a stochastic gradient descent or
longitude dynamics in this case
if you let your
learning rate decay like we do in
classical analyses
then you still get something that is
bimodal
uh for large time for reasonably large
times whereas if your noise actually
goes to zero at the global minimum then
here still we have a point cloud around
around a local minimum
but once it penetrates this energy
barrier once it gets into the potential
well of the global minimum then it
converges to the global minimum very
quickly
and so this is a kind of a capture
situation where once you once you get
into the region where
you converge to the global minimum you
actually never escape
all right so that is on the convergence
and on the loss but i promised you
a little bit more in-depth
um analysis of what kind of minima
we converge to
and the discrete time analysis for the
time stepping scheme is actually really
hard
so uh let's look at what a continuum
model would tell
us and
here instead of having the discrete time
stepping scheme i'm going to pass to an
a stochastic differential equation which
has the same kind of covariance
structure as the discrete scheme but
that allows me to neglect the
effects from finite positive step size
and so if we solve the continuous time
stochastic gradient descent sde
then the law of the parameters
solves the this pde
and so um to actually be able to do
something analytically i assumed a
particularly simple covariance structure
which is
still isotropic but no longer
homogeneous namely
the noise intensity has the correct
scaling but it does not capture the low
rank features that i was telling you
about earlier at all so i'm just
having some
constant
times the value of the objective
function that i'm trying to minimize
times the identity matrix
and then i can reformulate my
pde for the invariant for the
evolution of the law of stochastic
gradient descent
and so
if
here we see that
this is
the pde a stationary solution
well
if this is constant that the gradient is
constant and then the divergence is then
the gradient is zero and so is the
divergence
so there exists a trivial solution
um to this uh invariant distribution
problem
which has precisely this structure and
the one over eta sigma is essentially uh
given by how strong my noise is
so if the noise
is
if the noise is low
then this
focus then this concentrates a lot more
in the regions where f as well
and so um
we can imply a livable theorem from the
70s to show that
if
f essentially grows polynomially
so if the logarithmic gradient is
bounded by
one constant divided by one of a
modulus
then this is in fact the only
non-negative solution
to this stationary pde
and
in particular there may not be any
invariant distributions
the noise intensity gets very high at
infinity and that may actually carry you
away and prevent sgd from converging
um
so for comparison here if we've got some
constant times f to the minus one minus
one over here sigma and in the classical
noise case we've got this exponential
this becomes particularly interesting
if f is allowed to be zero because then
here we still have something bounded
whereas here
we see that we've got something that may
remain integrable
but which concentrates a lot more
sharply
at the set of global minimizers so we
see something similar to what we what we
observed before
and um obviously
the
i'm making the assumption here that the
infimum is positive and then i'm
analyzing the distribution if f is
allowed to be zero so there is there are
a lot of gaps in this but um this was
very curiosity driven and i think
there's a lot more to do in this
um so if i assume that i'm i've got a
density which uh an objective function
which vanishes on a high dimensional
manifold
and that the hessian has full rank so
that the
that the function detaches from zero
uh quadratically essentially
then i can then i can get an invariant
distribution which is integrable
and we can analyze
the
uh invariant distribution just at the
critical threshold so for small positive
noise the
invariant distribution collapses to the
manifold of minimizers and that's all we
can say
for noise which is a little bit stronger
we've got an invariant distribution
that is somehow focused around the uh
the manifold of minimizers i was curious
about precisely what happened
what happens if we approach this
critical threshold there's a question
yes
yes
the invariant distribution is not unique
so um and i can tell you something i
will tell you something about which
invariant distribution it goes you
converge to in a very special setting
so but in general you don't know it's
like there are no i don't so i don't
know whether the analysis that i'm doing
here is meaningful
um i was clear
i think there are situations where we
can prove something more than what i'm
going to tell you today
but um i do think there are a lot of
gaps
i do think this is a bit understandable
and so uh here
i was looking at the invariant
distributions with
noise that scales like in machine
learning
and with classical noise for the same
objective function
and so if i approach the critical noise
threshold where everything collapses to
the manifold of minimizers
either here as eta sigma
approaches the critical noise threshold
which is positive
or as the temperature goes to zero in
the classical setting
then here i get something that is
proportional to the determinant of the
hessian
in the directions orthogonal to the
manifold of minimizers whereas here i
get a different kind of average
depending on the hessian orthogonal to
the manifold of minimizers
and these two functions have the same
homogeneity but they are not the same
so if i just look at the simple setting
of a
code dimension two then a hessian
orthogonal to the
manifold of minimizers
is say one comma lambda
then the
uh then the classical noise where i take
the determinant and then take the
negative square root
would would give me lambda to the minus
one-half
so
essentially if i've got an eigenvalue
that is small
that tells me that the objective
function is flat
and that is a minimizer that has high
density so in that sense even for
classical noise you would expect to
converge to somewhat flat minimizes
whereas if i take
noise more like the one that we see in
machine learning then i don't get the
geometric mean of the eigenvalues i get
the algebraic geometric mean which
interpolates between the geometric mean
and the algebraic mean
and so
this
goes to zero
uh
like one over logarithm
so
here uh
if i want to say that a minimizer is
flat for machine learning scaling noise
then i would
have either to have both
both of my eigenvalues pre small
or one extremely small whereas here in
the clay case of classical
noise
one small eigenvalue is enough so i get
some different notion of flatness and
that was one of the main interests to
see how can we actually derive a good
notion of what it means for a loss
function to be flat because i think
that's not been done
and um
so
i'll gloss over this but i promise you
i'll tell you um so if my
loss func if my objective function
looks something like one plus theta
squared
especially on large scales
then i've got a unique solution of this
evolution equation and i get convergence
to the invariant distribution but this
is
if
my objective function is positive so
that's probably no surprise that i get
precisely this type of convergence
and the proof essentially
uses a punch array hardy inequality
youtube unfortunately
which was used to analyze fast diffusion
but this is kind of a linearized version
of that
now we can push this a little bit
further but under strong assumptions
namely i can't actually give you
something that vanishes on a manifold
yet i can give you something that man
vanishes at a finite number of points
and even then i need to make a very
strong scaling assumption between the
noise intensity
and the dimension that i'm in because
otherwise i risk the
run the risk of either running away to
infinity or collapsing onto my finally
many points so this is the only
situation where i can say something
about an invariant distribution which is
a density with respect to the back
measure
and
then i need
that essentially the objective function
detaches from zero a little bit faster
than quadratically at the minimizers and
grows a little bit faster
than
quadratically at infinity and if i've
got this specific kind of a behavior
then i can prove uh
punch array hardy inequality also in
this setting and then i can again prove
convergence to an invariant distribution
of the type that i've analyzed
but like i said there are
many open problems here there is the
validity of the continuum model in the
for the sde in the long term limit
um and analyzing the invariant
distribution for that
there is the uh fact that i've
proposed uh no stochastic noise which
has full rank
there is the fact that um
i'm
making some
growth
assumptions that are not necessarily
valid
uh there is the fair fact that i'm
analyzing
an sdd
version which is not the random pass
through a data set but which is
basically every data point has
independent every time step has
independent noise so there are a lot of
open problems here and i think this is a
really exciting
and important problem because
in training neural networks the good
behavior does not come from the loss
function so it needs to come from
somewhere else and so understanding what
this training algorithm does
is actually key to understanding why
neural networks work so well
and with that i would like to thank you
and
yeah
[Applause]
thank you for inquiring talk uh
questions
thanks it's a really nice thought i'm
just a bit confused with the
you have an assumption on the
on the
estimator of the g the stochastic
so you have this assumption
uh
between expectation like
here over here
the second assumption
is bounded about by f theta is this
assumption is this a consequence
so
this is an assumption that i'm making in
for this theorem
this is
a realistic assumption
for deep learning models in the sense
that the noise intensity
uh goes to zero as you approach the
global minimum which is zero
uh and in the sense that the noise
intensity goes up
as you
um as you go further away and have
bigger misfit in your points
um
i think a more realistic assumption
would be something like
expectation
of
gradient minus grad f
squared
is smaller equals c to the one plus
non-theta squared
f of theta or something like that
that i think would be a reasonable
assumption probably possibly a slightly
different growth
but um this is
the setting that was straightforward to
analyze so that's where i started
this condition with the just the peer
condition above
it feels like you just opted of each
other
um this pure condition is f is less than
equal to the
the
gradient of the law now you
it seems to as a consequence as a
consequence of the of these two
conditions together you also get a bound
that
the
is smaller or equal to sigma times
expectation of
gray um i guess
we are doing this point wise so this is
also smaller than gradient f squared
so you're right um this uh
the
uh that this basically
these two conditions together also tell
me that the also that the
oscillation in my gradient estimator is
on the same size as the gradient itself
um if sigma is small then that would for
example tell me that i'm probably in the
right half space
but sigma can be much larger than one
it just comes at a cost that you need to
take a smaller step size
okay
so yeah but but those two conditions
definitely interact here
thanks
yeah i was wondering about the
visa
you know these two different uh
uh
no measures on the ninth fold
like one with the scaling uh
so you mentioned the example of the two
dimensions right yes so but i was
interested in the more code dimensions
that depend on dependency on the
you know dimensions really because
one seems like the trace and the other
things
um so
yes uh here
if you've got uh if you've got code i
mentioned
here this one is very easy to understand
in any dimension the first one is
a bit harder because you need to solve
an elliptic integral
and that basically gives you this
algebraic geometric mean
which is essentially a compromise
between
a plus b half and square root a times b
um
and
i can
i can definitely tell you what happens
with the first one i've
not actually looked at what happens with
the second one in higher code dimension
and i really should
but the first one if you've got just
ones and then a lambda then it wouldn't
be lambda to the minus one-half it would
be lambda to the minus one over
co-dimension
right yes uh that is a color that is a
calculation that i should do
yeah
clarification question perhaps so uh so
this result was essentially shown uh or
something similar wrong this lines were
shown in a
paper by belkin and uh
so they they exactly make this
assumption and show under uh
convergence for sdd so
and also there's another result uh
under the same assumption
sgd escapes saddle points
and conveys to local minimizer at a
deterministic rate yes so
how what's uh what's the difference
between those existing research and this
analysis or this finite example
um in the finance regime so
the only results that i that i was aware
of in the same noise scaling
are for convex energies instead of the
pl condition but i
if you send me the paper and it's been
done before then i think uh i'll i
definitely want to have that reference
the uh the other thing is that that is
that the
i think the more interesting part is
the kind of global convergence result
which makes
which makes assumptions on the lost
landscape essentially
where the loss is very low or where the
loss is very high
but you make very little assumptions on
what the lost landscape does in between
and so it captures a larger class of
functions and so this i
i've not seen done anywhere before in
this um in this form especially because
there you really need to go a lot into
the analysis of what
of the fact that once you're close to a
global minimum you don't really go away
from there anymore so um
that is
i think that is the main technical so
this theorem that i kind of glossed over
is probably the main technical
contribution of the article
[Music]
[Music]
this is if this is
uh this is exponential in the diameter
and
i i don't think there's any way around
that there are computational hardness
results that tell you if i don't make
assumptions then i can't do better so in
a sense this is a glorified grid search
but it is but i think the
the the fact that you can prove a global
convergence result for sgd at all
is already kind of interesting
um and then
maybe if we can
understand the geometry of the lost
landscape better
and make finer assumptions then we
should get be able to get better rates
and i think that is also
uh one of the things where escape from
stationary points and
analyzing saddle points and
bad local minima where
possibly the low rank of the noise
actually helps you
because if you've got very high rank
noise then you're oscillating in a lot
of random directions whereas if you've
got
low rank noise which focuses kind of on
the main important directions
then you've got a much better chance to
escape your bad local minimum because
the oscillations kind of are only in the
relevant direction so the
rank of the noise it wouldn't be the
full dimension that matters but the rank
of the noise
so
i think there is
there is some room for improvement there
all right so
this is without another discussion
thanks stefan
see you